Okay, hey everybody welcome to Unit 1. In this unit
we're going to be basically discussing the basics of the web.
So, in this unit we're going to cover the web, what
it is, what it looks like, how, how their major
pieces fit together. We'll talk about HTML which is the
main document type of the web. We'll talk about URLs
which is how you refer to documents on the web.
We'll talk about HTTP which is the protocol that unites
the web, that the web runs on. And then we'll talk
about Web Applications and, you know, what they are and how
they fit into this big picture. And this is, you know,
the grand finale. This is what the course is actually about.